ポンヌーボー
中身が見えました中で見たんですけどもものなのかな2回目とリアクションていい
じゃん利用
何が届いたかと言いますと今回はこちらですねおっしゃいよねこちらですキャリー
バッグをいただきました
本当にありがとうございます僕ずっと青いキャリーバッグを使ってたんですけども
2年前から年前2年前だ2年前ぐらいから青いキャリーバッグをずっと
買ってるんですよね東京行くことも多いんであの青いキャリーバック実はこの海やの僕
キャリーバッグのタイヤの部分がもう壊れてて実は1年間ぐらいずっとね静岡東京行く
と魚常に何度キャリーバッグを引きずってる絶対に回らないんで頃がないんでころ元
タイヤが回らないで頃がない
その青いキャディバッグはタイヤが壊れてるんですのこのなることはないんですよ
こらー
朝ないでずっとあの青いて会社にバッグを引きずってね
何度も何度も東京に切ったんですなんかそういうのを気遣ってくれたらがわからないん
ですね多分そうでしょうねぼけ月年ちゃいまく2ずっと母子会競って東京に行ったり来
たりしてたんで
ループのみなさんありがとうございます見てくださる皆さんのおかげでもあるんです
けどもそこまでパサーボードしてくれてる人もたくさんいるんだなと思ってね一人たい
ここまで来たわけじゃないと思いますね
あなんか入ってましたこれ何か配線パターンならこっちはないぞ
待って会はがないなんだろ
me
まあ冊をからのかなラブライブのルームの社長だから頂きました
youtube のロゴですよええ
色紙かならもう
おじゃあ今回は泣かないぞう grow
うわああ俺こういうだーらー弱いんだなぁあんな100万に行った時はなんか色紙
みたいなまだちょっと変えちゃったんですけど今回は泣かないですかね
社員さん網羅しユーチューバーのか件のコメントがあります
おっ起業した方だだんじゃねーよ気兼ねし3部完
一日逆に書いてるかろー
あぶないよね
大丈夫だ俺はもう大人になったから大丈夫たくさんのコメントをいただきますか本当に
ありがとうございます
結構ねささえ上がれてるわけですよ
ブーブーんですけど
ブーブーこれで外れるんでもなんかやーいいんでちょっと今日はそちらを見ていい
クロスちゃんヌードルなーぐっ
ねうんもなくことないならことはないと言わず何をもらったんだろうという
ん
たしかそうだって大住なにこれ神はかっこよく
をロレッタがホンダ2人ともすぐ自分水をつければでぃスタイリング可能なべたつか
ないウォーターベースていいですロレッタのワッツをいただきました
blender の max とかっこいい匂いでとイクス
シャネルの香水ですねシャネルコスメいただきましたあと話ロック
パール48歯のホワイトニング
おやつですねなにこれろっちーたんティ
ロッチターンテロ字ターン t 乗ってきた洗顔る選挙秒いただきました
ありますからズッキあります今日6分いただきましたコメントも書いてありますまりっ
54倍増えてるから全部86万円がありますをいただきましたねーじゃねーか
目が疲れるんです youtube 同編集するから700万人の家
いやあこうゾーンとこトロフィーとかをいただいたんですけどもやっぱり俺もお寺に
練って分けてねちょっとされたバックスとか
構成使ったことないんですよ
は何度匂いがするんだろううっ
ええええええ
この3位形でこの入用なパーティーピーポー残念っていう存在はですねまぁこんな身近
な人でね今ちゃんと褒めてくれねちょっとはブームぐらいかなぁルームに入ってなかっ
たら炭酸くらいしか込められただったので
でも嬉しいでございます本当にありがとうございます鯉立つぁん学校が始まるで線
夏休みが終わって出ようよね僕もよねーなんて卒業しないといけなくて
卒業のための卒業論文って言う長い論文を書かなきゃいけな熱くねこれ
暑いうえ危ないぞこれ熱くなるちょっと暑いから外しと論文を書かなくちゃいけなくて
結構お金の先に忙しくなるんですよねこの先にその毎日動画を出して外もなかなか
厳しくなるってわかってるんで
ショットしたらこの先動画が毎日出すことができないというなるかもしれん
こちらですねまだ学生なんで僕の仕事は youtube ではありません
今の僕に自分たちながら大学なんで youtube の前にまずはちゃんと大学を
卒業するっていうそんなんか安いお金で大学行ってるわけじゃないんで
100万ってありがたい1宇宙もこのまま突っ走っていきたいんですけどもまぁ無理せ
ず一羽じゃない学卒業
しっかり床シート卒業してから自分のしたいことをしていきたいなと思っています本当
にいつも応援してくださっている方ありがとうございます
そして
サポートしていただいているいろんな the turn ムーヴも含め本当にも
いろんな方がいます
ユーチューバーの仲間と思います本当にいつもありがとうございます写真秋から小さい
額に力を入れていくんで
毎日楽しみにしてくださっている方で申し訳ないんですけどもうちょっとしたらだし
ない時が増えたりするかもしれないてその時はまあ大学行ってると思ってくれれば助け
ますって言うな
次回の動画でお会いし
しましょうじゃあ
ん
me